and nelson lamet on the hill today for
the friars and the 28 year old ready to
go try to take this rubber game he makes
his fourth start
that is strike three and a good start
for lumet he comes back and strikes out
quitel martay
and into the shift and right of machado
boy that was a tough hop but he comes up
with it that exploded on him off the
grass and right but a nice play by
machado in short right field
two down here in the first that ball
took off hesitation there and a
strikeout of sterling martay
lumet with a one two three first two
strikeouts madison bumgarner on the
mound for the diamondbacks in the finale
well after signing a five-year deal he
is winless all that starts the
diamondbacks have not won it's his
fourth start
right there ring them up and they
finally solve the riddle of fernando
tentes junior one out here in the first
inning for manny machado batting in the
two spot today for the padres machado
tries this to deep left fail peralta
going back looking up and it is gone a
home run from manny machado and the
padres take a one-nothing lead against
madison bumgarner two down france at
first and that brings up will myers for
the first time today myers to deep left
field that ball is back and that ball is
gone home run number 100 in a padres
uniform for will myers and it puts the
padres on top three to nothing
swinging a miss we played one
three-numbing christian walker to lead
it off against lament
he went around and strikes out third
strikeout for the bet one down
he's a fly ball headed towards center
field and grisham back a few steps
high sky makes the catch two down pro
far at first and the top of the order
tati is batting for the second time high
drive deep left field peralta is not
even going to move as that ball is gone
tatis second neck
home run in each of the three games of
this series fernando tati's junior get
to know that name machado homered off
him in the first to left down the line
does it have enough oh yeah it does solo
shot from annie machado his second home
run of the day
this is straight to home run derby this
afternoon from san diego dalton varshall
came off the bench in last night's game
and it's a start today in the d8 spot
swinging a miss and he strikes out
varsity fourth strikeout
he went around and he strikes out
back-to-back case for lament five and
all two down fastball from lament swing
in the miss 99 miles an hour and nelson
finally finishes him off six strikeouts
for lumet nine up nine down for lumet
and a six-nothing padre lead third
inning and taylor widener into face ty
france here's a drive the deep left
field off the bat of ty france and
that's gonna go
everything is going today
anything in the air has got a chance ty
france is first of 2020.
and
this one is in the air down the right
field line towards the corner it will
go
a two-run home run for francisco mejia
padres will take a nine-nothing lead on
home run number six of the day
down nine nothing and looking for their
first base hit against the nelson lament
grisham on his horse going back getting
there reaching up and he makes the catch
as he smashes into the fence and a big
time defensive play by trent grisham in
the right center gap here comes the o2
to calhoun swinging a miss another
slider he wasn't even close and now
seven strikeouts for denelson lament now
the pitch tried to check his swing could
not that slider down and away and there
you go eight strikeouts in four innings
for the nelson lumet and he has retired
each of the first 12 men to come back
time to go to work for the diamondbacks
offensively not a base runner yet
against nelson lemaitre has struck out
eight in four innings a swing and a miss
and he strikes out peralta nine
strikeouts for lumet two down
dalton varshall one hop backhander to
france at first hit bassman first base
runner nothing doing for arizona
a padres into nelson lament with a no
hitter through five only one base runner
he hit andy young with two out of the
fifth inning swing and a miss and that
is strikeout number 10 for denelson
lumet
comes in on him sounds like he broke his
back with a fly ball to right field will
myers tracking and calling into medium
depth right center he almost overran
that blue boy
and six note hit innings in the books
for the nelson lament all zeroes for the
diamondbacks as they come to bat here in
the seventh cole calhoun will lead it
off calhoun out to left field oliveris
will watch this one go
cole calhoun is third the first
diamondbacks hit and it's 9-1
on a day when the nelson lumet had not
allowed a hit through the first six
innings
pretty spectacular today through his 83
pitches
fly to center been hit by a pitch and
struck out swinging
andy young hits one to deep left center
field andy young has got a big league
home run there's one for west fargo a
two-run shot in the ninth off luis
patino that way kid
this is hit deep to center field and
nick ahmed sends one into the bullpen
don't go anywhere the second of the year
for nick
and that is strike three and that is the
ball game
but the padres take two out of three
another big day for fernando tatis
junior to nelson lamette